talk to me about whether schools should
be going back on the 1st of june
well i think schools should be going
back if it's safe and
one of the things that schools are
grappling with at the moment is whether
they can
safely reopen and comply with things
like social distancing rules so
some primary schools in my constituency
are going to go back on the 1st of june
but quite a lot aren't and it just
depends a lot on practical factors some
of the schools are
bigger they've got more outside space so
they've been able to put in measures to
do it
others are still trying to work with the
local authority to find a way
to do it my own child's school probably
isn't going to go back on the 1st of
june but they're hoping to be up and
running
a couple of within a couple of weeks
after that so it's important to get
children back into school of course it
is and
you know i'm like every family i want to
see my child back in school but it's got
to be safe and they've got to be able to
do it
right do you think it's safe at the
moment um
i think it can be i mean it just depends
very much on local
circumstances one of the things that
teachers
tell me that they're really worried
about is the fact that there isn't any
national guidance around it so
at the moment you've got a situation
across the country where
head teachers are trying to make
judgments um
often with the support of local
authorities which is very helpful
my own council has been really really
helpful and supportive to schools in
trying to make sure that they get those
measures in place
and but even the government has accepted
now that
for some schools this is going to take
longer and just giving a few weeks
notice probably wasn't the right way to
go about it
uh we're chatting to a gp uh from north
west london a second ago and he was
saying that he saw an increase
yesterday at uh surgeries after the bank
holiday weekend he doesn't know whether
that
is um because of uh blurring
of the boundaries when it comes to
lockdown rules given what happened with
dominic cummings and he doesn't know
whether
that could result in a second spike if
it does is it dominic dominic cummings
and the prime minister's fault
well i mean i don't i probably like him
i don't know why he's he's had more
people in his surgery but i think there
is a really
really big moment coming because we're
easing out of lockdown that
that requires a series of political
judgments as well as scientific
judgments and people need to understand
the basis of the advice that they're
being given and they need to trust it my
big worry about what's happened over the
weekend
is that i think increasingly people will
feel that they can't trust the guidance
that the government is putting out and
it's one of the reasons why
labour hasn't called for dominic
cummings to be sacked the prime minister
said he's not going to sack him
but we've said if he isn't going to be
sacked then the prime minister must
clear up a number of outstanding issues
about how it was that his
own advisor appeared to breach
repeatedly the guidance that he'd
written
otherwise we're not going to see public
confidence restored and my big
fear is that people will start to just
use their own
instincts as dominic cummings said he
did himself and
that will leave the country in a very um
bad place
we've heard from the prime minister he
says that he his advisor didn't break
the rules we had a very lengthy news
conference in the rose garden
of downing street end of don't we need
to move on
now and talk instead about how we get
our country out of lockdown
yeah i mean i think we do we haven't
just got the public health crisis that
we're currently dealing with but we've
also
got a huge problem in relation to
what we do now to try and get the
economy back on track just in the last
few days
um a major company you probably know k
shearings in wigan
went into administration hundreds of job
losses here thousands around the country
and and some of those employees have
worked for the company
for 25 years this is quite devastating
so we do need to move on
but we need to move on in a way that the
public can have confidence about the
advice that they're being given and the
decisions that are being taken
and if there's one rule for government
advisors and one rule for the rest of us
people will not have confidence and they
won't follow the guidance so
the prime minister urgently needs to
clarify why it is that he believes that
dominic cummings didn't break those
rules
okay so shearing's the is the coach
company yeah yeah it's a it's a holiday
travel company so
it's a slg so travel accommodation
and and the coach company's sharings
yeah but it's a
long-standing company um that was a
perfectly healthy profitable business
that went out of business because of
kovid19 and we're seeing this
right across the country okay let me ask
you a couple of questions
uh pertaining to your brief if i may and
nazarene sagari ratcliffe first
of all we are all hoping against hope
for good news uh today and that she will
be
pardoned um have you managed to speak to
dominic rob about any idea
yeah so i've reached out to the family
and to and to the
to ministers as well i'm really
concerned about the prospects that
nazanin might be returned to prison one
of the things that we
alongside the family have been urging
dominic robb to do
is to send the uk ambassador to visit
nazanin
as a show of solidarity because she was
granted diplomatic immunity
and it's really important that in a
moment of such distress that britain
stands up
and shows that it will stand up for for
families like
the nazanin and her her young child and
husband
um i i the family are understandably
very very worried that if she's returned
to prison that that could signal a very
lengthy
spell again in prison and after
everything this family's been through i
think we desperately need to see
um a resolution to this situation and
nazanin brought home and reunited with
her family
okay and you've also written to dominic
robert believe about the situation in
hong kong
what do you want to see happen there
well first of all i think the government
needs to
set out some concrete measures that it
wants both the hong kong
authorities and china to take an
investigation into
police brutality an independent
investigation is really really important
you'll have seen
the scenes from hong kong in recent days
the use of tear gas and pepper spray
against pro-democracy protesters we have
a
special and long-standing relationship
with the people of hong kong
and we've got to stand up now especially
because this isn't the first time
that we've seen china trying to erode
the provisions set out in the joint
declaration that we signed
several years ago these are the things
that protect rights freedoms democracy
and the rule of law and these are these
values are the basis of our
international alliances
around the world we've seen with kovid
19 how important those alliances are we
cannot afford to let them be eroded now
um and just before we let you go um i
won't go if i want to go to spain
this summer am i going to have to take
three weeks leave for a week's holiday
it's not at all clear the government
seven times has
announced quarantine measures and then
rode back on them in the last
couple of um couple of days they've said
that they want to introduce quarantine
measures where people
will have to self-isolate for two weeks
after they return from most countries
overseas
in the absence of any other measures
that seems to me to be a sensible
temporary stop gap but actually what we
need is a proper system
of test track and trace up and running
if people were tested
when they returned from overseas or even
better still
before they got on the airplane then we
wouldn't be in a situation where we were
having to ask people to quarantine for
long periods of time